there are many terrifying creatures and
monsters that can be found in Greek
mythology but none are as deadly or as
terrifying as typhoon while the war
between the Titans and the Olympians
were aged on the primordial goddess of
the earth Gaia could not bear to see her
children defeated and imprisoned and so
together Gaia and Tartarus created one
last monster their last attempt to repel
Zeus and the Olympians and stop there
all over the world that monster would be
known as typhoon typhoon is often
depicted in a few different ways the
most common being the torso of a man his
lower body was made up of the coils of
giant Vipers that would hiss violently
and attack anything that came close he
was as tall as the sky with large thick
wings his eyes would glow red and
terrify anyone who gazed upon them he
had a mane made up of hundreds of
different animals and his ability to
breathe fire meant that wherever typhoon
went devastation and destruction soon
followed when the Olympians first saw -
many of them fled and it seemed as if
Gaia's planned to help the Titans would
work but Zeus would not flee he stood
firm and a series of battles between the
two took place in the very first battle
- repelled all of the Olympians with
ease with only Zeus remaining he
overpowered the God tear and his tendons
from him and leave induce of no option
but to flee with Zeus wounded back on
Mount Olympus it fell to Hermes to use
his speed and guile to recover Lucis
tendons having regained his strength
Zeus knew that he would have to make his
last stand on Mount Olympus or
everything that he and the other
Olympians had worked for would be for
nothing he mustered all the strength
that he had remain in and held hundreds
of bolts of lightning at the Beast
eventually Zeus his persistence would
pay off as he overpowered - casting him
into the bottomless pits of Tartarus
it's believed that Zeus placed an entire
Mountain over where typhoon had fallen
in order to stop the monster from ever
escaping that mountain would be known as
Mount Etna and the ancient Greeks
believed that volcanic eruptions from
the mount and even nearby earthquake
were caused by typhoon trying to escape
his prison there are many varying
accounts as to the events that took
place during the Battle of typhoon and
the Olympians when all the gods
attempted to flee it was Athena that
stood firm and convinced them to stay in
a fight when Zeus had given up all hope
it was Athena once again who rallied
behind her father given him the courage
to defeat - in some variations Zeus's
lightning proved no match for typhoon
and he easily overpowered the god spend
in years torture in him Hermes and pan
were the only gods brave enough to help
Zeus and together they managed to escape
- - was sent to earth of only one
purpose to end the reign of the
Olympians and he seemed more than
capable of doing so if it wasn't for the
joint efforts of the gods to give you an
idea of the epic scale of this battle it
raged on for over 10,000 years and
hundreds of cities were destroyed before
typhoon was eventually stopped - is
commonly referred to as the father of
monsters and along with his wife echidna
together they created the majority of
monsters we know in Greek mythology
their children included than the maeín
lion the Beast of impenetrable skin that
Heracles was asked to slay as part of
his 12 labors Cerberus the three-headed
dog that protected the entrance to the
underworld villain a in Hydra a water
serpent of multiple heads that grew back
when they were cut off the chimera of
lycée oh the hybrid creature with a head
of a goat in the body of a lion capable
of breathe and fire it's also believed
that they gave birth to authoress the
two-headed dog and lad on the
serpent-like dragon that guarded the
golden apples in the garden of
asperities the Sphinx that was known to
kill those who could not answer his
riddles was also a child of Typhon and
echidna the Gorgons themselves are quite
similar in appearance to echidna and
it's no surprise that they also
originated from the father and mother of
monsters most of the iconic creatures
that we've come to know in Greek
mythology have come from Typhon and
echidna
- is quite a symbolic creature in Greek
mythology not only because he was feared
by the gods but also because he marked a
very important change in Greek mythology
the fall of typhoon mocked the end of
the war between the Olympians and the
Titans and the exchange of power between
the old God and the new
typhoons creation and sole purpose was
to destroy the Olympians but as someone
of a bi-product he became the father of
monsters and we were given a host of
extremely interesting creatures there
are very few creatures and gods in Greek
mythology that I would ever classify as
evil as there are often two sides to
every story but for me - is a fairly
good example of what evil looks like
he's only interested in desire it's the
course destruction in chaos
you could argue that he is only doing as
commanded by his mother and father but -
lacks any redeeming features that would
make him more than just a monster I
almost see ty Fionn as the Ragnarok of
Greek mythology the world is essentially
almost destroyed and in the process a
new generation of gods rise to power and
build a new world we can also see ty
Fionn as an example of the unstoppable
force that has changed in progress
the Titans refused to progress and
evolve and not even a monster as
horrific as typhoon was able to stop
them being dethroned I hope you guys
enjoyed today's video
I know typhoon was a heavily requested
topic and I look forward to hearing your
thoughts in the comments below as always
I've been your host Natalia Gian fiction
explained